chers amis quel plaisir d'être avec vous
ce soir merci merci d'être là
[Applaudissements]
vous allez me permettre de débuter en
remercieant ma famille qui est avec moi
sans laquelle rien de tout ça serait
possible mais trois enfants mon conjoint
ma sœur mes beaux-parents merci à ma
famille vous êtes extraordinaire
remercier également tous les candidats
qu'on a eu dans toutes les régions du
Québec remercier ceux qui sont avec nous
ici sur la scène merci pour la
merveilleuse campagne que vous avez fait
merci
remercier mon équipe une armée de
bénévoles et remercier le comté de Saint
Henri Sainte-Anne qui m'accorde sa
confiance pour la troisième fois
[Applaudissements]
le message ce soir il est assez clair
les Québécois demande au Parti libéral
du Québec nous demande d'être
l'opposition officielle à Québec
[Applaudissements]
pendant toute la campagne pendant toute
la campagne on a martelé nos messages de
rassembler les Québécois de se
rassembler de faire en sorte que chaque
voix puisse être entendu et plus que
jamais ce soir c'est important de faire
ce rassemblement là et là j'aimerais
m'adresser à tout les Québécois et à
toutes les Québécoises et vous dire une
chose que vous ayez voté pour nous ou
que vous ayez voté pour une autre
formation politique
m'apporte notre porte sera toujours
ouverte
[Applaudissements]
nous allons représenter tous les
Québécois et toutes les Québécoises
[Applaudissements]
vous allez me permettre également de
féliciter les autres formations
politiques François Legault qui vient
d'être élu premier ministre également
Gabriel Nadaud Dubois Paul Saint-Pierre
flamandon et Éric dum pour la campagne
qu'ils ont menée
et maintenant à vous chers militants et
chers militantes du Parti libéral du
Québec le travail a commencé mais il
doit se poursuivre on doit prendre tous
les langues qu'on a pris pendant la
campagne électorale pour parcourir
toutes les régions du Québec pour aller
parler à tous les Québécois pour faire
en sorte que chaque personne puisse
entendre sa faire plus faire en sorte
qu'on entend de sa voix et ça je vais
avoir besoin de chacun d'entre vous
allez vous être là
[Applaudissements]
alors je disais le travail ne fait que
commencer on a un élan on a d'autres
choses à faire au sein de notre
formation politique mais on a un outil
remarquable on a une force remarquable
et ça ça s'appelle la force de l'équipe
libérale qui est ici ici ici ici ici
partout
alors dans les prochains jours dans les
prochains mois dans les prochaines
années vous allez voir que je vais
déployer la même énergie la même
conviction la même ambition que je
caresse pour nous tous ici au Québec et
vous allez voir que ensemble on est
capable d'accomplir de grandes choses
pour un Québec qui représente l'ensemble
des Québécois merci beaucoup tout le
monde thank you tu vois merci beaucoup
tout le monde